as you progress through Need for Speed
payback you'll get the opportunity to
find derelict parts around the world and
turn them into your own supercar the
first one you can build is the 1965 Ford
Mustang
now you could follow the clues on
postcards you get in the game or you can
make it super easy on yourself and
follow this handy guide to get your
muscle car in no time once you've got
your motor up and running be sure to
check gamespot.com for more guides and
everything else you need to know for
neither speed pay back graveyard shift
if you find it come back to the garage
and we'll see what we can make of it I
heard is he used to fart around here
better check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
be all we need to rebuild the 65 Mustang
what kind of build you want for this one
the race build it'll go with a drift
build you'll have no trouble throwing
the back a drag build is all a run a
build is ideal for urban environments
the off-road is a setup that will give
you the grip and shocks you need to
survive bouncing around the sea look at
that classic 65 Mustang if that body
doesn't turn heads the growl of a v8
definitely will
[Music]
[Music]